dans la lutte contre le coc vide
on voit bien que l'état peut organiser
la lutte mais que cette lutte contre
cette maladie ce virus ne peut se faire
que si au niveau de chaque individu
il y à une prise de conscience
une responsabilité qui s'installent pour
faire en sorte que le virus
arrête de se propager il y a un rôle au
fond à la fois de l'individu mais qui
évidemment influent le collectif fair
nation au fond c'est être solidaires les
uns et les autres
oublier nos points de vue différents
pour passer le mieux possible cette
période difficile et retrouvé au fond la
grandeur du pays
comment s'en sortir sinon dans
l'immédiat que de faire corps et de tout
faire pour lutter contre ce qui est le
plus destructeur actuellement c'est à
dire le virus de l'aco vide
on a toujours la perspective d'un monde
meilleur
et l'histoire de notre pays a montré
qu'il y a eu des événements tragiques
dramatique avec des millions de morts
mais on avait toujours la perspective
que que sai mieux que la fin des
conflits arrive et c est bien là
nous avons la perspective de d'un monde
certes dont on n'a pas comment dire
la visibilité en termes de calendrier
mais on sait qu'il y à toujours en tout
cas je le crois profondément dans les
sociétés le ressort qui fait que le
monde meilleur est entre les mains de
l'ensemble de notre société que ce soit
les chercheurs les politiques les chefs
d'entreprise les enseignants je crois
que tout le monde fait corps pour ce
monde de demain et qu'on espère obtenir
les résultats le plus vite possible